How does an Etch a Sketch Work?
An Etch a Sketch is a remarkably simple device.
The primary components are just a small sheet
of glass; a stylus controlled by two knobs;
very fine aluminum powder; and tiny plastic
beads.
The tiny beads are mixed in with the powder
to make sure the powder will continue to flow
evenly and not get clumped together, as well
as aid in the re-coating process when you
shake the Etch a Sketch.
Each knob is connected to either a horizontal
or a vertical rail, which in turn is connected
to a pulley system.
This is all connected to the stylus via a
very stiff wire.
Among other things, aluminum powder has an
interesting property in that it sticks to
quite a lot of things, including glass, via
an electrostatic charge.
So by turning an Etch a Sketch upside down
and shaking, you effectively coat the glass
with a thin layer of aluminum powder, which
then adheres to the glass fairly well.
The stylus then simply scrapes off the aluminum
powder from the glass wherever it’s touching.
The lines this creates are black simply because
there is no light inside the Etch a Sketch
except what comes through
the lines you’ve created.